okay well let's play like a world
champion d4 we've seen no II for move so
far so world champion ish names Oh
Indian ah who's been following it Bishop
b4 no we're not having Bishop b4 land
let's take whoo I don't know if this is
right whoa the night ran away temple
gainer temple gainers happening
eventually however what is it that team
black might be wanting to do let's see
here if black is just striking my center
how would they strike in my center c5 so
i'm considering Bishop e3 right now
instead of a more natural Knight f3 hmm
huh
we try that should be three now what
mmm now I don't worry about c5 forget
about that if i play my night here
there's Knight g4 stuff how about I just
pin that night or play eight no no no no
no age three and then Knight f3 but if I
do h3 then Bishop here there's already
Knight takes pawn threatened let's do
this preparing to follow up with tonight
here if Bishop b4 i could play f3 if
there's a question throne okay let me
just do this defend I have a nice center
I'm reluctant since I have a space
advantage to make too many exchanges I
have more space to move about on so what
does that mean
if you have more space hang on to more
pieces maybe throw a question this
Bishop see what he once is what's his
story what's the story there well how do
i how do I am really shown advantage
here let's get this rook active he
wasn't doing anything in the corner no
what
okay let's come over here back it up
Queen here pawn push age seven I could
follow through with something like that
maybe now I could gain space space the
night has to run away where is he going
to run away oh I think this runs into
some trouble or does it now take the
bishop the Queen recaptures with check
if i play my queen here could the night
play here and just get away with it my
colleagues in trouble because now
there's two problems a the night and be
the move Knight b5 so this in between
MILF is probably going to turn out to be
an issue um you know what
I can actually do this because I still
have to threats still night be five and
the trapping of the night was the other
one no wait what am I talking about oh
man I don't have that move anymore my
bishop went here or my bishops no longer
here to watch over this Oh silly silly
silly all right let's regroup let's
regroup this night is still can't be it
can't be too happy can t I i'm not i'm
not worried about that night anymore i
push here the night's gonna go here
isn't he oh I have to worry about my
dark squares what a pain ah I'm out of
time hahaha hang on here hang on let's
come on over here here's my plan Queen
h4 night g3 actually no forget all that
my plan is just move fast move faster
than you've been moving I'm not gonna
keep this night away cuz he's not
bothering me on before so why do I chase
it away at night that's not bothering
you so now let's go oh man let's go here
next up I'm looking for I guess maybe f4
man now the nights of pain this better
work trade Queens no I don't want to
trade Queens no I'm gonna do this maybe
I shouldn't have played that for there
ah what a bug what a bug Oh get out of
here quit bugging me man
oh it's very scary my queen is misplaced
what a foolish piece ah man where did my
time go where did my time go I'll
pre-move time time burners no no no no
no right here you know you want to go
there mkay right here is it gonna be
alright better be all right Queen come
to the rescue please guard some squares
come on Queenie guard some dark squares
I'm just looking at d2 and III I also
need a flight square soon h3 will do the
trick it'll stop Knight g4 stuff as well
30 seconds high Eagles chewing up time
tick tick tick tick tick uh-oh ah
chasing me away to square was gonna go
to now he has to go here no he doesn't
let's go here defend stuff there's the
comment of the century right there
defend stuff yeah well done I don't want
to take hear that that's a really good
move I like Queen d4 let's make a flight
square please flight squared time Queen
make up your mind get out of there or
take my queen one of the two now I'm
weaseling back into this oh no you don't
actually they are going to kick my night
away all right let's go here I got to
watch out for these two squares what is
what's up with my time let's go oh no
no no no my books pinned I gotta come
over here Oh bloodbath on d5 let's take
quick quick quick no no no no no no can
take my rook oh oh I'm in trouble Oh a
mouse slipper everybody hates them out
slipper oh I know the feeling I needed
the mouse slipper even though I'm no no
come on go quicker go quicker oh that's
a bad one come on you could do this can
i pre move stuff I pretty move this one
right here right here give me give me
give me give me give me give me pretty
moves take that pond take that pond run
pond oh man
what does that movie even do
did I get it oh I was David Blaine in it
again oh man oh sorry for getting loud
chaitanya don't listen with headphones I
don't know how loud it gets but I know I
I get louder than usual when it's a
nail-biter that was a nail-biter I
should have won that I could sit back
but nearly every game oh there's so many
games like she just should not win did
you see the last time one that I posted
on YouTube I should not have won that
one either oh man I gotta go quicker
against high Eagle because he flies he
flies wow that was a clever line right
get it all right let's see what's the
scoop all right right here I did I
needed I don't know what I'm not doing a
good job with the space advantage i'm
getting here um so this is my first
suggestion you can't take with the night
because if you're playing against a good
player you'll get rolled over and I
wasn't buying a good player on the white
side here because here's the main thing
it's it's it's a tempo gainer i get i
get to advance my development and i do
it with the threat against your night so
this is something to avoid so the the
correct recapture is this and then you
know you're able to get this guy out in
one shop just along its classic diagonal
so that's my first suggestion i think my
other suggestions will be for myself
also be be cautious of obstructing the
sepan I'm still I like my position okay
yeah this right here I should have ran
in for it right here right here right
here quit and what you're backing up
just night here right now followed by
Knight takes pawn I think
however that might run into trouble
night b5 queen bee six Knight takes pawn
rook CA and my night is officially
running out of squares hmm hang on
yeah maybe I didn't have something that
maybe I should have done something
different here maybe I should just take
although this move really did seem
appealing hmm man good resistance here
this was an interesting move Bishop
there I thought it was losing is there
something better Night Moves I back up
ah man 85 cuz I was threatening just the
trap of the night what's what's the
story here I've hunted put a lot of
pressure on me the Knights repositioning
maybe I shouldn't have been so quick to
close things up but I was fearful of
losing this and black being able to
pivot on the e5 square yeah we're
getting well I'm way down on time at
this point but this is a this is this
next move ISM is good that pawn break I
think my opponent played really well
played some strong moves I thought I'd
be able to capitalize on it but I wasn't
able to thought I had something better
with that night b5 move but I'm really
not seeing it work out because of the
eventual rook c8 he's he grabs that pond
but he's after that he doesn't have a
good place to go to interesting game